حسنًا، حسنًا، انضمم إلي هنا في هذه
القاعدة العسكرية في بيلاروسيا، على بعد حوالي ساعة
بالسيارة خارج العاصمة، مما يعني أنه
يمكنك رؤية مدينة خيام واسعة بها كل
هذه اللوحات الضخمة التي قيل لنا إنها
يمكن أن تستوعب حوالي 5000 شخص
تم تشييدها  في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
كانت هناك صور عبر الأقمار الصناعية لهذا المكان
قبل وبعد، واعتقدنا جميعًا أن
هذا هو الموقع الذي ستتواجد فيه قوات فاغنر
المرتزقة من روسيا
إذا جاءوا إلى بيلاروسيا، وكان ذلك
جزءًا من صفقة تذكر مع
الزعيم البيلاروسي ألكسندر.  لوكاشينكو
يدعو فاغنر وزعيمها للقدوم
إلى المنفى في بيلاروسيا كوسيلة
لنزع فتيل الانتفاضة العسكرية في
روسيا الشهر الماضي حسنًا، أعني في
الوقت الحالي على الرغم من أن هذه الخيام
فارغة تمامًا، أعني إلقاء نظرة بالداخل على واحدة
من هذه الخيام الفارغة تمامًا هناك
لا يوجد أحد هناك، الجو
مظلم جدًا بحيث لا يمكننا أن نريكم من
الداخل ولكن يمكنني أن أخبركم أنها مجرد
منصات خشبية لا يوجد أحد هناك في
الوقت الحالي ولكن في النهاية يمكنها استيعاب ما يصل
إلى 55000 شخص، المشكلة هي
بالطبع أحداث  أمس هنا
مع ما كشف عنه ألكسندر
لوكاشينكو الزعيم البيلاروسي والذي
في الواقع هو أن هذه الخطة لم تعد قيد
التنفيذ نوعًا ما، إنها معلقة في
الوقت الحالي وفي الوقت الحالي أه جيفيني
باجوديان زعيم فاغنر ليس هنا
في بيلاروسيا الذي قيل إنه موجود فيه  لم تأت روسيا
ولا جندي واحد من جنود فاغنر إلى
هنا حتى الآن، ولذلك لا نعرف ما إذا كان
سيتم نقل
فاغنر إلى بيلاروسيا أم لا في الوقت الحالي،
كل ما يمكننا أن نقوله لك هو أن ذلك لم
يحدث بعد